hello and welcome to this video
sinquefield cup again round five yeah a
little bit later um this video is going
to be released then I originally wanted
but there was really no way of doing it
right after the round I had done the the
nice job of doing the live commentary
for the IC together with last bow hands
and grandmaster from denmark and we were
online for about six hours up to 22 a.m.
in the morning and after which i really
couldn't do a video i really had to get
some sleep and do it dumb when I'm yay
awake again the next day which is
exactly now so I'm I'm going to go
through all of the games are focusing on
one game in particular and do them do
the other sermon somewhat shorter form
let's start with Ireland roses mvl
Maximus Telegraph we got an open
Sicilian here Arnold is pretty regularly
playing the open society install and we
got a night off here but should be to e5
yeah what was a bit an uncommon is that
we she played this line that early queen
bee three line not happening that often
it's a it's an owner set up the ideas
that why does also using the Queen to
support if or maybe put a knight on d5
later this was played and now a 3
preventing any night before business and
why it's ideas ready to put night to d5
to get a situation where black quite
often will feel inclined to take that
night after which white will gain the
bishop pair because the Mystics bishop
has to take or in any case gain some
space with the pawn being on d5 and
black here has two options you can allow
that or you can play d5 immediately and
he did so after d5 we got those trades
and Queen txt 50 yeah Bishop Bishop
takes oops sorry bishop takes long
canceling fields risky
so Queen takes castles long and again
greet XG to hmm probably not and so
takes here and this position is very
close to equal for black but not one
hundred percent equal because why does a
little bit quicker with his development
and he can get some pressure with this
idea the night might jump to see 5 which
would be pretty pretty annoying thing to
face here and Bishop t5 yeah if black
takes that night he has to fight the
bishop pair which it doesn't want yeah
after Bishop d5 here um we we looked at
this position in the broadcast and I
know that last some thought f3 you would
be an idea playing this in a very slow
way and I have to agree I like that idea
playing it playing it slowly we don't
use an engine during the broadcast so
only later now I'm checking some things
that we have looked at life and here it
seems that 94 is pretty decent for black
attacking that night if you go be4 and
King c7 for example black is ok
sometimes can also take on on c5 which
concedes the bishop pair but also really
hampers wide structure um it was so it
was ok for black probably what I did is
sharper he played see for antiques and
rook g1 yeah now this is an interesting
situation if black moves that Bishop
white will have chances to play for an
edge chicken is insert insert that check
takes here and then take on g7 and oops
take on g7 which netsim lots of activity
it is better to do this what mvl that
sets a CLE cleaner and better move if
white takes with the night now Pusha by
three is very awkward this is a checked
and if you move the rook
this tactic is going to cost white the
game pretty awful so what what is it
that you should do if he takes with the
bishop check black has just totally
equalized equal material and white even
as the somewhat worse pawn structure
this is better there should be two
bishop f3 and now we get this this end
game I after some trades where why it
enjoys a slight advantage due to this
activity with that rook but it doesn't
seem to be enough really to get anything
substantial yeah this is what happened
95 and here's the counter play against
see for king of seven King is helping in
the in the center and black always has
activity here again see for which she
gets back so this end game it always is
better for wild yes and probably he will
maintain his pawn we see that check the
way it went he ultimately got that pawn
their own them on f3 check but at the
end it was a rook endgame and check the
extra porn was not really enough to do
something it is interesting that they
agreed to draw here even with white
being a pawn up yeah and sometimes is
doing that I'm giving relatively early
draws in positions where probably other
people would have played on simply um
yeah trying to torture the other side a
little bit or whatever yet just hoping
for some kind of miracle slip that the
other side is is doing objectively this
is really a complete draw or white gets
absolutely nowhere but it's it's hard to
imagine that that lets say magnus
carlsen would consider draw here with
white against anybody will probably
continue for a long while and i don't
know i still feel like maybe one game
out of 10
he will win because of whatever but
wishes sometimes doing that giving those
drawers relatively early on i remember a
similar occasions way just played four
against three on one side of the board
and yet the four points and he just
offered to draw which is kind of kind of
rare people usually try something at
least I mean there's nothing happening
most of the time but but anyway okay so
let's go to the next game let's go to um
what's next one in a camera Giri yeah an
open Sicilian so good news some
excitement along the way what is giving
doing he plays the tomorrow that this is
one of the main defenses that he has
against money for and nakamura is coming
with something sharp it's an English
attack style beginning with quick long
castles and then he went with f4 it
seems that it was a well-known line up
to a certain point that was some
obviously played and not obviously but
this was played before and they both
played reasonably quickly Queen f2 is
technically um novelty it seems but they
they played them they played this
quickly especially in a camera did from
now Gary took a little bit more time but
in general it felt like during the
broadcast the camera was definitely in
book while he had trouble recording
things or was maybe really playing over
the border this happened that trade
queen bee seven and rookie one white
looks some nicely mobilized Jenny's got
a full development looks are in the
middle of the board it's equal material
white maybe has ideas like f5 opening up
the center um black really needs to get
something going quickly anti-dust with
rook b8 attacking both bishops so white
has to give up one of them
happened and now give me focus attention
on then play on the fr White has a
vulnerable a to pawn yeah but Nakamura
it seems was still let's say in book and
played b3 King deserves a good place for
looking and now the move a for ya again
you see the ten minutes spent it seems
that he was still on in his prep a form
and give retook it yeah what was the
idea of a for the idea is simply that a
to was a target and against a move like
Queen a six you probably have to do
something you cannot allow him to take
with that a for idea you basically false
black to capture on pass all and now
you've gotten rid of the beep on and
this gives white some additional options
one we will see later in the game then
it's the move c4 at the right moment
also the White King after King a 2 at
the latest stage feels reasonably safe
it's a rather typical maneuver that a 40
I'm in mirror images like h4 h5 a5 just
to keep keep files closed here so here
the a file is closed by blacks own power
it seems that around here Nakamura was
struggling to exactly recall how he
wanted to play from there he ultimately
went for Luke t3 played that quickly but
later it seems that it seemed them that
maybe rookie to was the the more an
interesting idea rookie to King a to see
for that's the idea it's not quite clear
that rook I'm really needs to be on the
three in the game we see something very
comparable but we see that the rook is
indeed and somewhat vulnerable rook c8
was played movie too
and Queen B 5 very interesting player by
Giri what he is now doing is he
introduces ideas on c2 and d3 in some
cases and black really can take on d3
how could that happen let's say why it
was Queen h4 right to tag f6 a train is
happening and now that's it Queen text
III check and checkmate yep they pretty
quick enter the game this is why the
rukon d3 is really a bit vulnerable it
doesn't seem to be on that's not an idea
that probably will be repeated the troop
d 3 yeah Queen f3 was played and now
Luke a six by by my giri yeah we didn't
really like why its position so much
during the broadcast it took us a while
to really figure out that c4 is the key
idea and something that white
essentially needs to do yeah yes to
somehow pry open that position otherwise
black will consolidate and we'll just be
better so one maybe it is dynamically
balanced but um it's of course very
sharp and can easily um yeah lead to
trouble for both players so it's not
exactly exactly boring f5 yeah what
opens up the position i five it's
completely failing so that's no reply
Roxy six LED fields again quite quite
logical check stakes and back to d2
covering that why does a pawn down but
don't forget how potentially insecure
that King is where whites came on a two
is reasonably safe and we'll see form we
really have chances to open up the
position check a to was played king i
wanna you really feel uncomfortable
taking such a porn it's just safer to
keep that black porn as
as a shield and pick it up later yeah
now f5 was played that also again is
rather logical playing that phone out of
the attack um yeah now queen III
attacking this and somehow yeah tying
that rook to the defense of that pawn
and white also had stuff like G Froy in
this position yeah like this and yeah
here it's quite funny black has this
idea here check check check check and
it's a really really unusual drawing
mechanism but Queenie three is good and
probably also better simply because it
imposes a bit more problems rook g8 yeah
with this idea amongst others and ce4
that was the point at this particular
stage opening up the position against
blacks king black had to take chanted
check and came back stakes and queen age
6 as Nakamura it seems some stated after
the game he thought that this would be a
winning attack but it is not there is
just one move it precisely won't move
that secures the draw for black and that
is what giving played move Queen to be
six this is so holding that covers a
couple of crucial squares that that
Queen move yeah right now decided to
take that a perpetual check came back to
have eight and they didn't perpetually
could have played queen age six but
Queen inch for was a little bit of a
final final try that same but um yeah
here black has to go kini eight because
this is also threatened so he cannot
just take here check check
check yeah and this is going check
checkmate be made still can can stumble
yeah black played kini eight and now
Queen 85 was played and with the draw
offer because it really is a complete
perpetual yeah a good a good fighting
game and quite quite interesting a
battle with them both Kings being a
rather exposed we during the broadcast
we had some doubts about why its
position but ultimately he got enough
counter play going with that with that
c4 idea so on next games bring Aronian
with white against Grisha yeah ronnian
having a really nice event being on a
plus to score and he's now gone wide
against crucial piece was doesn't seem
quite in the best shape so let's see
what he's doing very very unconventional
move order him an interesting move
although that I also have considered at
one point to play the funny ideas that
white is going to play d4 and if that
pawn shows up on d4 there will always be
the idea of d5 so black fields inclined
to take that and it very likely leads to
a very unusual transposition to a chiro
card pun of attack that sounds we are
right but we will see exactly that in
the game Grisha plays Knight f6 t4 he
took it played d5 and after Knight c3 we
are in a coral and follow the tech quite
strange remember this position and i'm
going to show you the normal water
from the pan of it's like that with
exactly the same position yeah funny
sometimes what transpositions are
possible and well not everybody who
plays c4 c5 it's a knowledgeable in the
panel so interesting and move all the
tricks um British upgrade plays Bishop
g4 now which is them traditional
mainline another line that has been
becoming popular recently as g6 this is
how I play in this position it's an
interesting somewhat sharp our
alternative but Bishop g4 is of course
good and now aronian plays Bishop g5
that is an unusual move it is not played
often at all then overwhelming me not
yet as he takes 90 x and queen bee three
where white tries to make good use of
his somewhat quicker development um
Bishop g5 whatever was played and now
gree shock had to solve this over the
board one reason I'm form this early
deviation certainly is um the fact that
Grigio is that note Oriole notorious
time trouble addict a very often gets
into enormous time pressure and getting
him to thing go and yon might be a good
idea now he played a sixer as you see
after more than 20 minutes um what else
is there an idea form is actually an
interesting move yep white will probably
move that bishop again let's see here
Queen 85 then or more conservative is
this and it's not so not so apparent how
black will continue here you can maybe
take on c3 employee 6 or play six
immediately it's just an entirely
different position to what we usually
have in
in the panel p.m. so interesting
innovation here by aronia Bishop g5 if
leg takes here by the way G takes is
some is ok and white has quite a bit of
pressure on that center we would see in
the game that after e6 and takes takes
check that check was played and here wyd
will for some weakening of the pawn
structure we should be six and now here
the pawn structure was damaged black
couldn't take with the Queen after 95
Queen D 893 black seems to be in some in
some danger because we checked miss
White's development seems very very
problematic Queen here for example yes
to like reckon with this and antiques
shanks kinga seven looks a bit awkward
even though this is probably not super
great for while it still feels a bit
uncomfortable he took with that with a
jeep on and now we have a weird
situation other let's put out a couple
of moussaka we should say something
about this black castle long and it
looks unconventional but where else yeah
short castling seems hard to do keeping
it in the center is also not very very
sensible so probably black has to Castle
long um we during the broadcast we
thought that why does them somewhat
better in this position which is maybe
also due to the fact that both the
Grandmaster Hanson and I we have mostly
about them more strategically focused
players and we value structure highly
and like structure is kind of a mess but
of course he's got the two bishops and
this discount for something and the open
G file can be useful as well we see that
black is actually quite okay we really
didn't evaluate that correctly it seems
yeah rook g8 black directly uses the
fact that he has this open file nothing
to be underestimated whenever there's a
double porn there's also some additional
open file for rook that's really
something that needs to be really
understood the broad structure is not
everything in a game if you have double
points the rooks will get more active
forget more opportunities to to use open
files and he again rook g8 it's a bit
term and submit them difficult now
castling and bishop 83 a clear a clear
tech there on the g2 phone it's
interesting now that g3 was a
possibility that would be a yeah quite
an uronian style he likes to play a
strategic sacrifice ocn the style of
Tigran Petrosian the famouser country
made let's say of aronia former world
champion something like this or maybe
Bishop takes I don't know what's
possible White has very decent
compensation for that exchange because
the light squares will be totally in his
hand but on the other hand it's hard to
imagine that why it really would be
better in this position I mean it might
be enough but better probably not so an
even tougher so you have to really give
the exchange there and it's not an easy
decision you went night age for rook g4
and we see that Grisha is getting kinda
plain this is nothing to be sniffed at
takes takes black could have considered
this now we during the broadcast we
thought that this was a possibility and
we see something something similar
happening
the game that was played and now Queen
d3 attacking the bishop taken and G
takes 83 and now Queens have fun yeah
this is some this is a strong maneuver
one idea is that the main idea is that
after the Queen f4 Black is ready to
play Bishop to d6 building up that
battery on age two and this introduces
this piece into the game the bishop on
f8 wasn't doing much beforehand so a
strong strong move um now it seems that
Queen a six balsam wasn't was a good
choice but aronian played look see one
looks totally normal but it doesn't seem
to be that great and because of this the
king up to the six that is probably
really really strong and now once you
see that move you get an idea that may
be why it has somehow overplayed his
hand a little bit because we should be
six will come and the king is rather
save on unknown on d7 rookie one Bishop
t6 and King f1 you have to do something
there and now it it already feels
uncomfortable for white this is dropping
j yeah okay let it has a very simple
idea but it's also probably useful to
coordinate pieces shouldn't forget black
is a pawn up in this position and it's
not so clear that white has a huge
compensation for that King b7 was played
um the engines do suggest Quincy for him
the idea being that say here black guy
was Queen B 5 and keeps that that pin
um keep zap inactive it's however rather
difficult to play this position I mean
we shouldn't underestimate that koushik
was down on eight minutes and eight to
nine minutes and he has a history of
spoiling stuff with no no time on the
clock so maybe he was rather going for
his save option with that King King to
be 792 25 a queen for was a bit tougher
Queen see two books in for a shock and
here we see that white has gotten a pawn
back Queen d5 threatening in this and
after the trade they agreed to a draw
yeah pretty sudden end to to that game
and maybe a game where in fact gris
shock had the better of it we really
didn't usually didn't have the same
opinion during the broadcast we felt
that why should have something brilliant
with this better structure but the way
it unfolded blacks initiative got really
really strong and here with whites
structure being that damaged and black
finding that nice Queen f1 Bishop b6
idea he had in fact more than more than
equalized so a good game here by both
players and Aronian was a little bit
lucky maybe that that grease shock had
that time pressure and couldn't
capitalize on his a good position in a
better way with more time on the clock
probably a.m. that would have been would
have been more danger for white I'm
losing that game okay let's go to the
next one yeah the next game is to Paul
off with white
note that Apollo with white can scare
wanna yeah you can really see how strong
this event is when you get aware of the
fact that we have the leader of the
event to pile of playing the the last
place term participant kawada was the
world number what is he like number
three number four number four right to
Parliament on atom number two and three
yeah so corona is in last place with
minus 2 and this is showing how strong
that event is okay what do we get get
them Berlin defense which is not really
yeah notorious for being super exciting
but I can promise you that the game will
be interesting and this is partly due to
the fact that white went d3m which
really seems to be the main line
nowadays on the on the top level they
have it seems pretty much exhausted that
end game at least for the moment and
people have switched to that slow and
it's slow way of playing the position
where black is not under direct pressure
but white is some keeping pieces on the
board and can hope to outplay black in a
long long term battle 97 yeah that idea
was already played in an earlier game to
pile of Nicole Brown do you form b 6
Wrigley one yeah and now that took part
of nakamura game I actually didn't look
it up I think them I think my camera
when I g6 down or see 696 corona has a
different idea he plays the bishop out
to g4 and I like that idea is activating
that bishop and putting up this this pin
in general blacks idea is to put
pressure on white center is given up the
center temporarily and now wants to
initiate some play down the bishop would
that pit helps with this
play again the center and the only
drawback possible drawback of that is
that sometimes white can go g4 and win
lots of space on the King side where the
bishop can be sidelined on g6 or later
on h7 of age 6 s play so it's it's a
kind of a double double sided affair so
it's it's a difficult difficult to play
this position right I like this idea
that this Bishop is active now and the
pile of went queen bee three D 5 D 597
no black has managed to clarify the
situation in the center and it feels
like he's very solid however he doesn't
have much space this is important White
has a huge space advantage and the way
he plays it would expand even further
let's see a for ya threatening a five
black just played a five himself to stop
that and now the Queen was going back to
d1 the idea was that the night wants to
go to be three and this son helps to
play against the c5 break open up the
bishop and the queen or the one is
actually doing some job yet looks at
that f3 knight so that in case of a
capture we have an easy recapture on a
three once the night is on b3 um ip8 huh
very original play yeah let's let's put
this on what this and this adopt it
totally looks like there was this and
this play yeah night be a to c 6 niga to
e7 in fact that's not the case both
nights have switch roles here but this
is coming to e7
and this has even a longer way to its
current destination yes it looks weird
but then it's important to not be a to a
dogmatic about things if you move things
pieces move them twice three times four
times in the opening and it really
serves a purpose and doesn't make an
okay they cannot be punished really then
it's okay here blacks regrouping it's
probably quite quite useful even though
um I remember that during the broadcast
we thought that white would have a
pretty pleasant position here because of
his advantage in space um let's see what
happened Bishop to g5 age six Bishop age
four and it's important to note that
here in this position black cannot grab
stuff because queen g-form is immensely
awkward that it takes them the bishop if
it returns let me draw the squatters
correctly and if he returns now he's
basically losing the game yeah something
like g6 will delay the demise but it
cannot stop it it is just far far too
dangerous and now in that picture 1 m6
so Queen c8 and now g4 that was
something that I already had mentioned
um earlier this reform will quite often
can be used to gain a temple on that
bishop and prepare a further porn
expansion on the kingside Bishop g3
right before ok 3 e 3 night a 2 we have
that pendulum yeah now rook see one
would be an immediate draw but that was
not to palos intention as it is usually
he is a fighter and he doesn't want to
concede early draws yeah so ultimately
nighty one was played that doesn't look
him that attractive yeah it's a retreat
and it's not really active looking move
but it was one of the few options that
actually let right continue and it's not
a mistake just that it's not the most
natural move ever not e to c6 Queen d2
and Queen to e6 yeah black is connecting
connecting works yeah this one was a
critical position one of the critical
positions of this game and here i think
that the next move is probably a bit a
bit questionable and two part of not
took on c6 and this took us by surprise
because we couldn't really determine why
white would play that move it was a bit
mysterious to us
at the moment black has two nights down
and they are kind of stepping on each
other's toes and we didn't like that
decision why would why take on c6 I mean
he gives up the the two bishops a bit
mysterious we I didn't turn as i was
doing commentary i didn't watch the
official broadcast and maybe they had an
interview later and they explained down
their reasoning but Bishop c6 really
seemed wrong to us Queen takes and the
night IAM is activating f6 that's an
important black does not want to sit
passively but rather wants to break open
the position and tries to make some use
of his two bishops yeah and the next
term couple of moves are probably very
very important what the power of now no
goes for is very ambitious but probably
questionable he plays Knight f4 Queen d7
and now he plays the movie 6 and with
hindsight we probably can state that
this is um this is probably really a
mistake that poem on e6 is more of a
liability than an asset why doesn't have
any good support for it and we will see
that it will rather quickly be encircled
queenie seven rookie one got a little
bit of a server delay yes and now kawana
went f5 that's a strong move Blackett
wants to open up on the King side where
the g4 push has weakened White's king
also a bit
nine to five and six now black has this
idea g5 I actually painted that but the
server current they have some issues in
g5 okay it takes a while but it it comes
up yeah we really see that that fallen
is sixth is somewhat detached from the
rest of whites forces um he really is in
some trouble however what top i love nor
did is probably not helping it'sit's
uncomfortable but he is now a going for
material sacrifice roxy 3g 592 and after
f4 he sacrificed um he also could have
played them instead of this if we check
this here yeah rooks III in them instead
of instead of 92 he could have gone to
beach five this wouldn't have lost a
material yet after something like this
but of course that's not exactly what
you wanted from that game em if you have
a bad bishop the somewhat strange night
something like Bishop g6 intending to
take will be will be better for black so
we went for that sacrifice and after
night d three it's a double attack
that's the only move nothing else
otherwise blankets just up so much
material so roped XD three visual h6
Andrew k 3 yeah whatever yet position
Black has a has a rook manhole rook four
three ports but white still can put his
pawns in
and at least be very very irritating in
fact during the broadcast we were sure
that right white is not having enough I
mean it's it's really a look for three
points but the three actually 37 it's
just two points um we were reasonably
sure that there was no and no draw for
why that it wasn't enough but to
actually prove it over the board is a
different matter however kawana is doing
a really good job there Queen age seven
is a good coordination move and what was
really really good was he a queen g6e
seven and now the very strong-willed
queen to d6 we were really impressed at
how strong that move is black and some
attacking e7 twice and also introduces
the possibility of going in there and
now it will be very awkward for wise to
play if he takes the bishop queen age 6
s very pointless for what and what else
is there that that white can do if
Bishop f4 this is okay and black again
will probably be winning in the game
Queen e7 once played queen bee three
check check yeah and now we see that
after this rookie tonight will win so
queen of one is forced and in fact here
if black takes on h4 after Bishop b5 the
whole situation is not entirely clear
why does have some compensation here
quindi 3g tix for example would be very
dangerous check but this is now played
Andrew gave eight this continuation by
Caruana is just much much stronger than
going for that
position with still Queens on the board
here the bishop is attacked and they
have three Pawn go for check they played
a couple of moves still and check yep
again falling with check be five and
take stakes yeah and now the a pond is a
huge force the white Bishop really is
not in good shape only five to stop that
corn so nice win IAM for kawana stopping
this um this one led to pile of head in
the last event Norway chest and he and
the first rounds of the scene feel very
important for the overall standing of
the event that at a pile of loss that
game and koala with that wind with the
black pieces definitely um yeah seeing
some light let's say at the end of the
tunnel after he's started badly they
both have resting so the decisive game
is always very important directly before
the rest day because what happened there
was directly influenced your mood yeah
for the whole day that you have off okay
now let's go to the main feature of this
cards with white with the specialist oh
yeah 24 again yay accountant had a good
game with them 93 against mvl could win
but switches back to one year for now
yeah we got an ID off which is a slight
surprise not that so it's going for the
night of you often does that but cars
are playing the open society it's not
that common nowadays usually he would do
that with some idea in mind and this
time he really placed them the sharp
main line with Bishop e3 um well is it
the main line it was for a long time at
least but it's one of the sharper
continuation that's what I'm getting it
if you place the opening sometimes when
play like g3 or h3 those kind of moves
there should be three is definitely more
vicious v 5 you had this kind of setup
so it's going for a b5 based approach
black can also play h5 as we had already
seen earlier in a game all set group to
Paula Otto part of Greece yoke it's hard
to say I could have been both ways I
forgot but that that has been played
earlier in the event between those two
players b5 is allowing that g4 move yeah
a very sharp position is coming up
Knight b6 very interesting now why it
really has to do something about that d5
pawn like is attacking it twice and you
cannot just mechanically defend it a way
to defend that would be to take on b6
but that is definitely not what white
and wants to do giving up that good
Bishop only three against at night it's
not so much Bishop against night but
it's also about the dark squares why
it's dark squares here I kind of
weakened and you don't have a clear way
of of continuing 95 interesting move by
cars and he's already taking some time
so it's not that he had to prepare that
although all the way Knight takes d5 and
94 so has white just given up that porn
for nothing an interesting question
actually and it's not that easy to to
see how White's compensation really is
looking like he has compensation but
it's some purely strategic compensation
there is no direct threats happening or
something drastic that will yeah we will
attack black quickly and why it has that
nice pieces in the center Bishop only
three and night on c4 and some pressure
against that poem
six quite often it will also occupy on
d5 um how does that translate into
concrete moves and so now took only
three let's say he wouldn't have done
that yeah what what about casting for
example then g5 becomes an option and
now after night takes III white can play
em Queen takes III that looks good on at
first glance but black has funny
discoveries yeah based on the fact that
this is winning probably this is the
more interesting move 1961 only move and
takes here Queen takes Queen txt one and
hear what I think has pretty good
chances to get a light squared blockade
going on on d5 it's not clear cut not at
all but I think I'm white can probably
satisfy him Wesley took only three
immediately Knight takes the idea is to
control the light squares castles Bishop
c4 that is now a very natural
development the compensation that white
has is based on the fact that whites the
light squares are weakened whites night
has possibly good invasion squares and
like it's rather passive with this
bishop on his 797 was now played by
Wesley so that seems to be a good move
during the broadcast we also thought
about d5 and this doesn't seem so bad
actually Black is just giving away that
pawn and make sure that he trades off
something in the process something like
this and this
I don't think or we've let's say we
didn't think that like I said in huge
trouble here but on the other hand you
understand that he didn't really want to
return the porn that quickly especially
if you have alternatives that look
decent um night peace 97 again was the
move and it's an interesting one and
after age form he played me at first a
596 was also possible if I've important
to understand of course that black
cannot take on edge for due to Queen h2
that's terrible meydan h7 so black has
to play this and after nine f5 this is
all a very very sick joke here this is
collapsing this is impossible i
just--that's losing why just as far to
watch him yeah a5 was played as I said
Knight b6 was a very sensible
alternative g5 rook c8 bishop t 5 9 p-6
King b1 all that looks fairly normal
Queen c7 yeah instead we also thought
that rook c5 is an idea that tries to
fight for that d 5 square not sure what
white would have continued yeah probably
I mean Bishop b4 comes into
consideration or queen bee three some
move that does something for the light
squares if white plays rook h2 f1 as it
happened in the game we might get
something comparable just that the rook
is a bit more active on c5 this year was
what's happening rookie have won by the
way is a little move but a nice one it
tries to make some sense out of that
look and f4 f5 would be really strong if
Y it manages that yeah trying to use
that bishop on d5 f4 possibly f5 or
opening up there
yeah a very difficult decision now for
black he ultimately decided that he
cannot tolerate that bishop undefiled
and took it of course it's a it's a
trade for trading a very strong bishop
on d5 off for allowing a super strong
night to d5 we definitely see rather
clearly that white does have
compensation for his porn is it more
than that that's difficult to say but
what we shouldn't underestimate is that
if an engine tells you that this might
be equal I'm not completely sure what
the engine will give if you give it some
time I think it gives white a slight
advantage here at least when i checked
it briefly but this is only half of the
story the thing is that this position is
exceptionally difficult to play for
black because the knight on d5 is very
dominating black cannot challenge it or
force it away and this bishop only seven
doesn't look very very active and it's
not really going to change in the next
couple of moves White's play is just
much easier and this is a very important
thing to take into account this is
something that a computer evaluation
cannot tell you some sometimes the
engine says okay equal and this is
really fun analytical point of view the
case because if you find like 20 year I
had the only moves in a row one side
might draw but the human player does not
find the 20 moves and here it's only on
a less drastic level it's the same thing
White has clear plans here it is f1 and
black hands to defend not very very nice
f5 probably that's necessary otherwise
if white gets an f5 himself it will be
too ugly yeah let's say you play move
like that and white pushes intending
attending this it will be very awkward
and
and you can even argue that there are
alternatives like h5 first with h6 being
an idea so I I do understand that f5 was
played simply stopping this Queen III
putting some pressure on e5 and black
Wendy form yeah getting a protected
passer sounds nice but it doesn't do
that much at the moment that that
passport so the knight on d5 is
dominating the proceedings and now h5
what is why its idea we will see Luke c5
and h6 that is a very nice move I'm very
nicely played by the world champion if
thats taken queen bee three winces put
that with that pin and after age six and
black plays g6 that's not not much
choice there we have a very unique or
let's say rare formation on the Kings
side white has established that pawn
shade all the way up to age six and we
know from many classical games are from
from well-known instructive games that
installing such a pawn near the
opponent's king is an extremely
unpleasant thing to defend against any
white check really check might be fatal
Queen og 7mate if you look in weights on
the second rank ooh probably also yeah
close to impossible to defend this
position is really difficult to play for
for black even though computers don't
agree am with any evaluation better than
white having a slight edge maybe this is
what's true where that black can defend
but doing that over the board no that is
very very difficult queen bee three
provoking book f7a for that's a good one
keeping the queenside close and
utilizing this of course Bishop d8 rook
t4 king of a droop t1a widest piling up
we see that White's play is very easy
and natural he just activates his pieces
and he doesn't really have to worry
about very much the e4 pawn which is
black some extra porn does not go
anywhere and roof is six back to e3 and
Bishop and b6 was played yeah why it's
idea with regrouping the night or
removing it from that nice outpost was
the following night to see for looking
at a five looking at t6 and this some
now gets really concrete quickly be sure
to default
why sorry I skipped a skip one
opportunity I'm rook takes d6 was an
interesting alternative that I just
forgot to mention takes takes and now
oops if Bishop takes Queen three this is
actually winning Queen d4 is very very
strong yeah I rook takes t6 wasn't was
an alternative but hasn't played this
move and i think it's it's also very
strong it might not be as strong as the
other but it is it is good enough we
should before and Knight a5 Queen had to
move and takes yeah now I'm Quincy six
roop t4 oops rotiform we wind the pawn
they're rather easily and with the rook
entry on the eighth-ranked white will
also win in the attack not just by
material so Bishop c5 was played and 25
just centralizing III and a5 going to be
5 and now we see the winning maneuver
White has made sure that the queen is
leaving the protection of the d8 square
and now the night is going for
full-scale invasion Luke a seven-shot
check one is 68 and 94 that was more 14
that's important to understand instead
of this 94 move um cards and had night
xe5 which as some computers will tell
you immediately was stronger yeah with
two minutes on the clock or something
like that it's not so easy to to be that
precise however it is pretty clear once
we
look at the lines how good it is Queen
takes d5 Queen G giant King 27 check
check yeah this is a typical line and
white is winning then there is no
counter play whatsoever move like e to
check oh that was badly drawn move like
that is just losing rather quickly
however cards didn't take on safari
plate 94 maybe also due to the fact that
he didn't as I said doesn't have so much
time Queen a5 and here at that
particular moment one has to realize
that why does actually um not that safe
with his own king queen a1 checkmate
okay what if white covers it with 93
unfortunately I'm Jack check checkmate
this is rather embarrassing so white has
to be careful here you cannot just play
routine moves like 93 and be good can be
better because it's getting made it yeah
council took a bit of time and then
ultimately decided to check check check
them came back to c8 check again the
check King up to be seven
yeah and now why to play and win yeah
well let's say play forward if you you
want it like that it's not easy as I
said Queen night b3 is not saving and
ultimately it seems that the way to do
it here for white is the move funny move
c3 i actually had suggested that during
the broadcast simply because i didn't
see any other move to continue yeah
otherwise you're getting mated or it's a
perpetual and that was the only move
that it's not one of the two then it is
actually indeed winning I didn't really
understand when I suggested it was just
yeah one for the candidates that same
but it is it is good c 3 black took
probably no alternative if you check it
didn't have it all other it's no I
checked yeah it takes check we'd be
three check that is a point will be six
yeah now here Queen Texas free was what
we expected during the broadcast and it
is it is a strong move after Queen takes
we didn't really see what what black has
black has left he doesn't have any
meaningful checks or whatever and why
does maybe just threatening to play
something like night back to e2 blocking
that pawn and then marching up the
h-bond and this is a threatened anyway
now aged seven is a serious move here we
didn't find any any decent reply at all
we thought that black is just lost and
this is confirmed by by the computer
afterwards cards now ever surprised us
and took on g6 yes that great technical
abilities so maybe he was just comparing
and saw that okay in the other line
queens are on there might be some kind
of counter play against the king of I'm
training Queens
and this end game wins as well maybe
trade queens to avoid anything anything
awkward happening so this might be the
rationale behind it it turns out that
what is indeed completely winning in
that in that rogue and game played them
Bishop takes d4 now black did nightly
two of the threat simply pushing it to a
position where it is completely
protecting white spots and then pushing
the edge porn yeah this is where black
took and now important the little detail
rook takes this is threatened with a
check yeah so that e to check come on
it's not working at all King c6e
Dwight's King was going up yeah the best
is relatively simple why does combining
play with this age porn with that play
against the e porn and ultimately the
wild rook was entering the position and
black cannot hold all those pawns grew
cage to c4 and here um black restless so
resigned yeah that was a good game of
thing bye-bye cards and he could have
won um a bit quicker and that time and
trouble time trouble phase of the game
but he never really met a win slip it
was always from that when he got that
winning position he never really left
that evaluation he could have done
things and I said more forceful quicker
whatever but keeping the winning hand
and not giving any counter play often
it's um is a good recipe you don't need
to play all the top engine choices all
the time to have played a good game if
you play let's say the second best move
instead of a plus-5 move you play plus
three move you're wanted in computer
lingo then this is very often just a
good or sometimes the plus remove is in
fact the better move because it might be
the one that is easier for you to play
if you have the choice between being a
piece up and nothing happens in an end
game or being let's say let's say three
pieces are Borg Queen up or something
and the other side still has a weird a
check against your king then by all
means I want to take that that piece or
that two pawns and have the end game
that I win in my sleep other than having
something better on paper let's say that
it's still tricky to play this is
something that the computer of course
cannot evaluate it just shows what he
thinks or what it thinks is best and
that's not often the best human
continuation here also that Queen trade
by cars when the computer says of course
that's a mistake because keeping the
Queen's on will win quicker that might
be true but after that as mentioned he's
winning that basically in his sleep and
then why not if you would use the risk
of going wrong it does make some sense
to just trade Quincy end and win from
there okay that was coverage of round 5i
hope you enjoyed it round six will be
played on saturday so we've got a rest
day um yeah I'm covering around six and
the ongoing or the following ones of
course as well but yeah make sure to
remember there is a rest day on Friday
so there will be no single cup video um
directly afterwards or saturday morning
my time okay well guys thanks for
watching